the pandemic erased two decades of
progress in math and reading ACT scores
are the lowest in 30 years anxiety and
depression way up drug overdose overdose
deaths murder is way up inflation at a
40-year high domestic violence increased
what you don't have is the benefit of
the alternative scenarios to see how
they would have come out to be able to
judge whether what did happen was a
lesser evil than other options that
would have unfolded and so so suppose
somebody actually we do because other
countries handled it differently Sweden
didn't handle it differently some of the
places with the lowest vaccination rates
turned out to have the best results
you just you just said we can't make any
judgments because we don't live in an
alternative Universe where America
handled it differently and I'm saying
other places handled it differently that
does matter him talking about it waking
up some people is good